how about this
mr neidor from india clever name
yes all right i'll go for up for pawn
yes pawn
you know the drill yeah i know the drill
so night
oh yeah i shouldn't shouldn't have
played but
no no yeah a pawn okay
all right pawn
we're back to this i'm going to say
bishop
i'm not a place in pawn expert
this is tricky stuff this is tricky
stuff indeed
and i'm certainly not updated on this
i'll go for uh go for night i guess
can't hurt
but remember we're short of time so we
have to
call those pieces out quickly yeah uh
pawn
pawn okay
these positions are so hard they are
it's not mine i'm not my cup of tea but
mr neither of his thinking
and we're fine but we're certainly not
out of the woods yet
that's for sure that's for sure
what oh that's certainly a weird move
i'll go for uh i'll go for
bishop looks good
so far so good
could have been worse could definitely
been worse
we've seen worse nighters than this
only remains to see if mr najdorf is a
good night earth
right queen
queen where do we go
i think we'll kick the knight away
reasonable enough
i have no idea if i've done what you
want so far but
probably it's all cool probably not
right yeah
logical very logical
right on right on okay
yeah it seems like yeah we're doing
pretty well
uh i like i like black uh queen
we have the bishop bear that's an
unshakable fact
damn i didn't see that one uh well pawn
queen
that was a good move oh yeah yeah
e5 was certainly not expected
by us yeah we're just thinking bishop
bear great position but
now it's a little more tricky well you
know
it's uh it is what it is i guess
at least we have a pawn yeah that's a
neither
right always always a lot of tricks at
least before you can castle
absolutely absolutely that's how the
theory goes
but uh now for sure
your practices yes as we say in
norwegian
pawn then if he takes the bishop
wow wow a pawn
i feel like that was maybe a bit over
aggressive
yeah same here uh bishop probably
now this is looking pretty good we have
three connected passers in the center we
have the bishop pair
there is no way this could possibly go
wrong
i agree so all right a bishop
uh pawn
we run absolutely a bishop
look at these beautiful bishops
queen centralization
exactly what i was thinking
two brains are greater than one that's
for sure yes
uh king
we're not afraid yeah it's no time
either so
uh rook
all right maybe bishop
okay okay oh maybe
there was a better bishop move maybe
indeed well bishop
okay uh pawn
yes we're not afraid king
thank you sir you just gave us a good
score for your king for our king
absolutely now maybe we can uh
just rook i guess
okay that's simple yes sir rook
rook
queen queen
okay oh you can't okay he couldn't have
taken the knight
well queen takes g3 was a good response
then
yeah it seems raining on time anyway
probably would have been
would have been okay yeah indeed